connor is with us connor's in
minneapolis hi connor welcome to the
ramsay show
hey dave hey kevin thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so hoping you guys can resolve a debate
between my wife and i on how much do you
spend on a car
um so a little background on us we're on
bb steps
456 we have no debt other than our house
and no kids yet
sorry a little nervous okay what's your
household income
what's your household income yep uh 200
000.
and what's the other car worth
um about 17 okay and what other toys do
you have with motors in them or wheels
on them
uh just one other car that is not worth
a lot that is falling apart
so no no no boats or sea doos
or snowmobiles or whatever
no nothing like that and we have um
currently 86 000 cash on hand
okay so what does she want to spend on
the car
she wants to spend five to six not
nearly enough
what i was thinking like twelve to
fifteen
i would say twenty twenty five twenty
twenty five you make two hundred
thousand dollars a year you have no debt
you have eighty six thousand dollars in
the bank
you need to buy your wife a good car not
new
but a really nice one-year-old or
two-year-old car
you guys are being cheap skates
well there is a little catch dave um the
one piece being that
in the next one to two years i'm
planning to go back to get my mba
and my wife is a teacher so she only
brings home about 42 a year
so don't quit your job your mba is an
executive program at night
why would you give up this fabulous
income to get an mba
um i think long term it's probably the
right move so i went to school
for history and political science and
ended up falling into a really good job
i don't i think you make too much money
to quit your job to go get an mba i
think you get your executive mba
at night it's the same mba dude
and you keep your job yeah what do you
make
uh 156 last year so you're going to pay
156 000
a year for two years to go get an mba
that's dumber than crap
yeah where are you going what you fell
into something where you where are you
headed with this nba you think it's
going to take you somewhere where
so um right now i work for a health care
it company um and kind of the second
caveat uh with this
is that um i'm going to be rolling into
a new job in the next year here
my remote work i work for a company
based out of wisconsin
that works ending so i'll be going to a
new job i don't the income's not going
to drop to nothing
but it should be around the same area
given my experience and
skills and kind of the references i have
um future though i'd like to
work my way up to like a ceo or ceo of a
hospital
i didn't say don't get an mba i said
don't pay 300 000
for it yeah do it as you go
okay i mean really opportunity cost on
your money is one of the things they'll
teach you while you're getting your mba
you're pay you're giving up 150 000 a
year for two years of income
to get an mba when you could do it at
night in an executive program
and there's tons of high quality
executive mbas all over the nation
that you can get into and they're about
20 grand and go get your mba mba is a
is a wonderful field of study is it
necessary to be a ceo
no but it's helpful it's good i would
suggest it i don't have one but i would
suggest you get one i got several of
them work for me
and um so but you know but dude
you're paying too much side issue so
that's that changes the car discussion
and you're right that is a uh
a piece of context around the car on a
teacher's salary did we do that are we
going to cut our income by 150 000
so it brings up a larger discussion i
think but um
so i think you go by 20 if you want my
advice if i was your dad
i would tell you your old uncle that's
kind of grouchy and speaks too plainly
um you know i would say i love you man
and don't pay 300 000 for an mba do it
at night
go get your mba live your life have your
career field that you like
it it's probably table stakes to some
degree in the in the world that you're
in
and uh but but you know it is not
necessary for you to give up that income
to get it and that means that you've got
eighty six thousand dollars piled up to
buy your wife at twenty thousand dollar
car
yeah i absolutely agree pay as you go on
the nba
and learn how to follow you're gonna get
opportunities to lead that nba is gonna
be real
nice it's gonna look really good but by
the way if you're working for somebody a
lot of them will pay for it
yes sir they will absolutely if they
want to invest in you a great company
wants you to get that
uh i there's no hurry for you to go get
that mba
there's just no hurry if he's changing
jobs i'd like him to get in and get
settled
let's see what the latter looks like in
this new company let's have that
discussion
but you know i've not used this phrase
before but it is the phrase it
is the right phrase we have told
too many people and too many people have
believed that a degree
of a certain level a degree period
or a degree from a prestigious
university is table stakes to be
successful
it's not it's not at all you get to play
at the table
and it's how you play the hand and does
it give you an advantage
in some cases it does then you know
having the knowledge base
is a good thing but there is there is
absolutely not a
single piece of research that says where
you went to school cause you'd be
successful
matter of fact there's contrary research
absolutely let's give you a good
old-fashioned football recruiting
analogy you can have a five-star rating
or a four-star rating from
from a recruitment organization and you
can get recruited based on that
but you better go and you better show up
and if you don't play well you won't get
on the field i don't care if you're
five-star or not
if you don't play well if you don't show
up in practice
and do what it takes to show it to get a
chance to play on saturday
you won't play i don't care what your
rating is and that's the nba it's nice
uh it says that you've gone and done
something
but the reality is dave you're right you
got to show up you got to be humble
you're still going to have to work your
way up the ladder
by being a good follower learning how to
lead and then applying
that wonderful knowledge to real life
leadership
and that comes through delivering
results yeah but the the nba is not
willy wonka's golden ticket it is not it
is not going to get you in the ball
cinderella
yeah uh you know what gets you in the
ball is you know
your results yeah well you you actually
do stuff
that's right now it can it gets you
noticed sure you know can it get you a
side-eyed glance
yes it can like that but it doesn't but
it doesn't
it does not cause you to get let me just
tell you we're hiring for
you know six figure positions every day
here we're hiring 300 000 people around
300 000 300 people this year god help me
um 300 is enough at ramsey this year and
several
many many of them are business
leadership roles tech
leadership roles that are six figure and
not a
single one of them will be hired because
of where they went to school
that's true not one not a single one of
them will be hired
because of their career level or be
turned down
i mean because of their education level
or be turned down because their
education level
the only thing we are concerned about is
do you have the tools
to do the freaking job
you know i had a guy working for me
years ago i said you know guy with as
many degrees as i've got
usually makes i mean more degrees than a
thermometer i mean you know he he's like
a guy many degrees as i've got makes a
lot makes x number of
dollars and i said well honey you're
working for a small business and
around here your raise is effective when
you are that's good it's my favorite
line
that's so good but that's you know and
didn't make him happy he didn't work
anymore but the um
you know because he want to be paid for
because he went to school now you get
paid for doing crap
that's it that's all it is scoreboard
kill something
drag it home so in his case the mba is a
good thing
good thing is it table stakes does it
mean you cannot succeed
no would it probably open some doors yes
with the knowledge base you get
definitely open some doors and give you
the ability at a co level to function in
health care
yes and he's in the financial situation
where he can cash flow his way through
it yep
and they might pay for it absolutely i
mean health care is big on education so
you know there's a lot of different ways
to play this but what i want to take off
the table for him
and for everyone else is that it is
required
or it is a golden guaranteed ticket
certificate you will succeed because you
have it
no over-educated broke people are
everywhere
yeah they're everywhere they're all over
our culture
and and and they're arrogant as crap oh
yeah but they're broke
here's the line dave a degree is not a
guarantee
that simple touchdown there you go not a
guarantee
it it might it might get you a side-eyed
glance
across the ballroom but that's it
cinderella
you've got to make tackles you got to
block you got to catch the ball too many
metaphors
mixing up cinderella's making tackles
now i don't know this ain't good buddy